hi everybody happy Wednesday and thank
you for joining us for our monthly
workflows with posit team session by
popular demand today we're going to talk
about using your company brand in a
shiny app while this example highlights
shiny you can also use all of these
techniques with Cordo and our markdown
documents I found that incorporating
your company brand can make an impact on
your data storytelling but making a
great first impression you can Elevate
the initial perceive quality of your
content and encourage greater
adoption so I'm really excited for us to
go through this example today and as a
reminder we host these sessions on the
last Wednesday of every month at the
same time and same place here on YouTube
where you can find the recordings of the
nine previous sessions as well if you
have suggestions or a workflow that
would help make life a bit easier for
you please let us know in the YouTube
chat here or over on slido if you prefer
to be anonymous you can use use uh
YouTube and slido to ask questions
during the demo today as well at the end
of the demo you'll be automatically
directed over into another YouTube live
room for our
Q&A with that I would love to introduce
Garrett director of developer relations
at posit and one of the earliest
employees at our studio among many other
things Garrett is the co-author of R for
data science and an author of The Lu dat
package thank you so much Garrett I'll
turn it over to
you we're going to start with a basic
app that looks like this and slowly turn
it into an app that looks like this
along the way we'll lay out the
components of the app with the BS lib
Library We'll add cards and value boxes
with icons like you see here we'll add a
logo we'll change the color theme to use
brand colors we'll apply the theme to
our plots and we'll change the fonts
that appear with throughout the app I'll
also link to GitHub in my app and
publish the app deposit connect now this
app is written in R and that will be our
Focus today however everything that we
can do you could also do with the shiny
app origin in Python but of course the
code that you would use would be
different so let's get started and that
means logging in to an IDE where we
could develop our code for me that means
pait workbench and inside of posit
workbench I prefer to work in the Art
Studio Pro IDE so I'll make that
selection and start a new section for us
to work
in so workbench launches and here's the
r Studio IDE the next thing I need to do
is get the code that contains my app see
I've already been working on this app
not necessarily collaboratively but I
have prior art that I want to start with
and that code lives on on GitHub in this
public repo it's Garrett Gman at shiny
styling DDO so if you wanted you could
download this code for yourself clone
the get repository and that's what I'm
going to do I'm going to clone it into
my workbench session to do that I'll
copy the URL I'll go back to R studio
and I'll make a new project when I make
that project I can choose to make it
from a Version Control repo in this case
it's a git repo and I based in the
GitHub repo I also need to choose a
directory name to clone that repo into
in my local file structure I'm go to
shiny styling
demo so I create that project our suu
clones the repo Imports the code
refreshes the r
session and now I have all the contents
that I get Hub repo these are local
copies that I could work with and then
if I wanted to I could push them back to
GitHub you know with typical git
development practices our studio adds a
git pane here which is a gooey pane that
I could use to do the typical git work
like commit Push Pull create branches
revert and so on but today let's just
focus on working with the apps within
this repository you'll find a folder
called finished app this contains the
code that creates the finished app we
looked at but we're not going to look at
this today because we're going to make
this and we're going to make it from the
directory called be
app that contains the first app we saw
if I run the app we could take a look at
what it
does so this app contains data for
fictitious company called democo or
demoo uh they sell imagine them selling
a premium software product users can use
the product for free but they can also
upgrade to a paid professional level
service with more features demo is
interested in what they could do to
convince their users to upgrade to the
paid professional version so they've
tried out two types of free trials that
last a different amount of time one
lasts 30 days that's trial a one lasts
100 days and the app shows data that
they've collected over the past year at
the success of the free trials at
converting users into customers versus
the success of not offering a free trial
it's designed to be a portal that we
could give executiv so they could query
the data themselves for example they
could filter down to specific customer
segments within the data and the app
will respond to their
selections so that's what the app does
but I don't think this app looks very
good I like the sidebar layout that puts
all of the inputs right where you expect
to find them but this endless scroll is
not very userfriendly
also this looks like a basic shiny app
out of the box it doesn't really look
like a product that demoto might use
internally so let's see what we can do
to change
that now we're going to start working
with this code and to make it easier for
us to follow along I'm going to add an
extra column to my
ID I can do that by going to this panel
icon and selecting pan layout and then
I'll just add a
column I'll apply
that
and then I could put some code side by
side and that's what I'll do first I'll
take the base code we'll put over here
this is our app and in this Untitled
document I'll just copy all this code
into it so no matter how far a field we
go we at least have you know some safe
ground to return to we could close the
finished app and we're not going to use
these panes too often so I'll minimize
those just so we have some more screen
real
estate I'm using a large font size so
not as much fits in here but I'm hoping
you'll be able to see the typing a
little
better so we want to create a new
UI so out this goes and let's just pause
for a minute to reflect on what our
strategy is going to be
first we're going to give the app a new
layout then we
will add a cards and value boxes we'll
see what those are as we add them next
we'll add a
logo
then we'll change the theme of the
app and we'll work with the colors in
the
app then finally we will work with the
fonts in the app and then Super finally
we'll publish the
app all right so how do we do this how
do we change these components of a shiny
app well there's one package in
particular that we're going to use to do
most of these tasks and that package is
called the BS lib package so BS lib
stands for bootstrap library and
bootstrap is a very popular framework
for CSS and HTML development and every
shiny app is boot built on top of the
bootstrap
framework what BS lib does is it
provides the most new and up-to-date
bootstrap features in our package so our
users can take advantage of those
features it works seamlessly with shiny
apps because it's developed by the shiny
team it also works with our markdown
documents and even Cordo documents
because those documents are also built
upon
bootstrap in fact boots BS lib is so
integrated in the shiny that is imported
by the shiny package so if you've
installed the shiny package you already
have it and you could start to use it in
your app and that's what I'll do
here I will tell the app that we're
going to start using some functions that
come from the BS lib package do that
with Library BS lib and then the first
functions we'll use will recreate the
app page Force now I said that I really
like the sidebar layout and I meant it
and that's what I want to create a page
with a sidebar typically in shiny you
might do that by calling fluid page
giving a title panel then you'll call
Sidebar layout and give that a sidebar
panel and also a main panel and you'll
put your contents inside of
there BSB provides a slightly more
efficient way to create a sidebar app so
let's take a
look we'll use the function page sidebar
which comes in BS lib it takes a title
argument we don't need to use the title
panel helper we could just pass the
title straight to that argument so I'll
copy and paste that from over here and
next it takes a sidebar
argument and we use a helper function
called sidebar with that argument
whatever we put inside sidebar will
appear in the sidebar and I have this
object called sidebar content we'll look
at it in a second but it contains
everything I want in the sidebar and
then finally to use page sidebar
anything you want in the main panel you
just list as additional arguments
outside of
sidebar so we put everything else here
literally now if we run this
app we'll see what we get so this is our
sidebar app and one thing I want you to
notice right off the bat is the styling
for this sidebar app is a little more
modern a little more upto-date versus a
typical shiny sidebar app for example we
have a built-in widget to expand and
close the sidebar and you can see other
styling differences as well so where did
these things come from if anyone's
curious these are just three widgets and
some text and I saved them as a list in
a helper file called setup. r that my
app is sourcing so down here you see an
object called cybar content which is a
list this idea of grouping widgets
together into a list is really helpful
pattern if you plan use the same set of
widgets in multiple places throughout a
shiny app or across shiny apps I'm just
using it today to keep screen real
estate focused on the things we're
actually go be touching so that's where
sidebar content comes from now
everything else I just typed but that's
not really what we want in our app we
want these things from our old app over
here let's pull just a couple of them
into our app so we could start working
with laying them out before the screen
gets too crowded so if I put things into
my page site
bar be a li or shiny We'll add them one
beneath the other as if each new item
was plac in a new row and if I continue
to do that with all the items I have
I'll be back at that endless scroll
which is what I'm trying to avoid really
what I want to do is place the items
beside each other as if each new item
was a new column and there's a function
in BS that allows me to do that it's
called layout columns so let's add that
here and see what
[Music]
happens call layout columns and you give
it as much content as you
want close the
parenthesis and now if I run the app
those items are organized into
columns so this is good this is a start
but we can see a couple things here the
first thing I I see is these are four
different items but the character
strings are really just titles for the
plots and they should probably travel
together I don't want them in separate
columns I want each title and plot in a
single column and then the next title
plot and so on in a shiny app you might
collect these things together with
something like a well panel but BS lib
introduces A New Concept called a card
that I'm going to use here if I want to
collect two things together in a card I
surround them in the function
card and then if I want the card to have
a title or a header I would wrap that in
another function called card header the
reason for that is it'll make it easier
for us to style that header a little
later on so let me go ahead and do
that and then we can take a look at what
we
have all right so now our apps and our
titles are bound together visually in a
way that I think looks really attractive
there's even a drop shadow in there and
we have our app starting to look like
where we're headed to the next thing I
think I want to do is I want to change
the width of these two plots I think the
line chart deserves more width than the
bar chart it'll just make it easier to
see what's going on there maybe those
dates won't be scrunched together and so
I'm going to try to make the line chart
about twice as wide as the bar
chart the layout columns function makes
it really easy for us to do that we
could do that by adding a new argument
called call widths an underscore in
there and we set it to a vector of
numbers one number per column to set the
width for right now we have two cards
that means two columns and I want to
make the first card eight units wide and
the next card four units wide now why am
I choosing the those numbers layout
columns is going to take whatever
horizontal space is available to it and
divide it into 12 relative
units they're relative because you don't
know how wide the user's window is going
to be and the user might actually change
the width of the window while they're
looking at it but Leo columns will make
sure it's always dividing the available
space into 12 and now I'm just
apportioning that 12 units between these
two
cards and here we we go I've created
that that width that I like but there's
more cards to add to this app and I want
the extra cards to be on a new row below
these cards I could do that with the
same layout columns function here's how
it works if I want to pull over the
remaining
elements just start with one
element I'd add it here I'm going to as
before wrap these things into a
card
and then as before I'm going to give
this new card a width let's say we want
this to be four units wide as
well layout columns divides everything
into 12 units so if you ask for a width
that exceeds the 12 units layo columns
will simply put it on a new row below
the first so this four unit wide card
will spill over onto a second
row and this is how I create a grid of
columns and rows I just plan out the
units and put things where I want
them I could even offset things in here
if you want negative space somewhere in
your column or your
row just say how wide you want that
space to be and then put a negative
number in front of it so I could insert
three units of negative space here I
have four numbers now only three cards
that's because one of the numbers refers
to empty space And now when I make this
app provided it's wide enough I see I've
moved that recommended trial
over that gives me a lot of freedom I
don't really want to take advantage that
for you today but I wanted to show that
to you what I want to do now is pull in
everything and make the final
layout now as before I want to be
careful
to collect these items together where
they belong
together so bear with me while I do that
make sure I close every new
function all right so I have some new
cards so I should apply some new widths
here uh let's make
every card except the last one four
units wide that will take us another 12
units so that'll be a second row and
then the last card I'll have span an
entire row by itself I'll make it 12
units
wide uh oh looks like I forgot a a comma
in this case these are all arguments of
layouts columns functions so we got to
have commas between each new
one and here we go we have our app now I
have all the widths the way I like them
but I don't have the heights the way I
like them I'd prefer to give a little
more height to the charts there's more
visual information there and this table
you know we could scroll within the card
so I don't mind compressing that a
little bit the way I affect the row
Heights is by adding a row Heights
argument to
layout columns so I have three rows I
want them to have relative units of four
1.5 and three now no matter what numbers
I put in here Leo colins is going to use
the entire vertical space but by
choosing 4 1.5 and three I'm determining
how wide those rows are relative to each
other and there we go now this is all
laid out but there is something I see
here I see a lost opportunity each of
the cards in the center row only shows
off one value BS lib provides a new
object called a value box that can
really emphasize single values and I'm
not using it but I would sure like to so
let's go back to our code
the way to use value box
is to call the function value box from
the BS library and value box doesn't
require a value header or anything like
that we just give it a title and then we
give it the content we want to appear in
that value
box let's make all three value boxes at
the same
time
and rerun our
app and here we go so now these are
value boxes one of the the big
advantages of using a value box is you
can add an icon to that value box to
explain something or Draw your user's
attention or just make your app look a
certain way so I'm going to add icons to
these value boxes
the value box function takes an argument
called
showcase and showcase should be set to
some sort of Icon now how do you write
an icon in R well there's a couple
packages that could help you do that
like the font awesome package for font
awesome icons but I'm going to use the
BS icons package which contains
bootstrap icons there's about 5,000
icons that come with bootstrap as I
mentioned we're using bootstrap all over
so I like the idea of just sticking with
those icons but if there's 5,000 icons
how do I know which ones I want to use
well for that you might turn to Google
or the web I think this is the best
website for searching through bootstrap
icons they're all here you see there's
quite a few and there's a search box at
the top so if I want an icon related to
money I might do this and see some
things this coin one catches my eye and
so on I'll try to make sure this link
ends up next to the video that you're
watching all right so let's go back to
our app let's make some icons so I've
loaded the
package now to pass an icon to Showcase
I use this helper function called bsor
icon and I give it the name of my icon
so I looked through the icons before we
met today and I decided I'd like to use
an icon called stars for this value box
which presents a
recommendation and I would like to use
an icon
called people- fill for this number of
users and finally for this average
spending I want to use that coin icon we
just looked at now I rerun the
app and if I give enough
space we have the icons not only that
they introduce some color into our app
this isn't the color I want to use at
the end of the day but anywhere you see
color in your app you can change the
color later on to make make it fit your
theme so this gives us something to work
with now this is a nice looking app
there's one last thing I want to add to
it before I start tweaking the details
and that is my company's
logo I'm going to put it right here in
the sidebar and to do that I'm really
just going to rely on the fact that this
app is a HTML web page I use HTML to
drop an image right in there and then
the user's browser could place that
image into the app the way they place an
image into any web page page that the
user looks at to make that work takes a
two-step process in
shiny the first step is I have to get
the image to the user's web browser and
in shiny you do that by give by
supplying a www folder this is a special
folder in shiny everything in the app
directory is going to be passed to the
server that serves your shiny app so the
server for example have accessed all the
helper functions the data set that uses
to build the plots and
whatnot but it's not going to be passed
to your users's web browser there's no
reason to give user that data causes
security problems maybe uh definitely
makes the download time increase it's
just doesn't make sense so it doesn't
happen but sometimes you do want to give
something to the user's web browser like
a CSS file or an image in our case and
you could do that by put it in a folder
named
www I've put our logo here in this
folder along with another file I'll talk
about later here's the
logo it's just a PNG image anything in
this www folder will be giving to the
users's web browser where it's available
at the top level of their web
page all right so that's step one the
users go get this image but where should
the browser put it I have to tell the
browser that and like I said I'm just
going to use basic HTML skills are a
little undeveloped or Rusty but I think
I remember an image
tag let's use single quotes something
like image and then I have to set the
source the source is going to be this
file which I said it's available at the
top
level I'll set the width going to make
it 100% of the
sidebar and then for the height I don't
really know what it would be but just
you know whatever works out when the WID
is 100% so I'll use Auto and there in
the HTML tag and you could look this up
on Google if you need to see how to put
an image tag in there but it's just a
character string if I leave it like this
shiny's going to think it's a character
string that I want shiny to display in
the sidebar instead I want shiny to
treat it treat it as HTML so I'm going
to surround it with this HTML helper
function from the shiny package now when
I run the
app the app the browser puts an image
right there uh it's a little hard to see
but there's some white text in this
image it's the complete logo but
obviously when I came up with this logo
I I was envisioning an app with a dark
background so let's shift gears and
start tweaking the app changing the
colors changing the fonts and getting it
ready to
publish how do we change the colors in
the app well once again we're going use
the BS lib package and this time we're
going to use an argument called theme
that comes in the the page function from
BS lip and we're going to set it equal
to BS theme also from the BS Li package
within BS theme we could choose any boot
Swatch
theme like the minty theme for example
and tell B to use that theme for app a
theme controls colors fonts all the
styling in your
app this didn't change anything so I
must have missed something here BS theme
boot SWAT
M uh let's try this
again where are my arguments here
boot
Swatch
minty got commas I got parentheses oh
that does seem like what I just did so
let's rerun
this and let's see if the console is
telling us something's
missing all right well stop the app I'm
not sure what's going on here but one
thing that I can do is restart the r
session sometimes when you're working
with theming there is some caching that
happens in the the browser and in other
places and restarting the r session
we'll rule that out as a
challenge and here we
go so this is a new theme it looks a
little different it's the minty theme I
can even see some of my logo text here
however this is not necessarily the
theme that I want my app to have it's
just just a demonstration that we can
change everything all at once and that's
always a good way to
start let's suppose we don't know any
boot Swatch themes how do we choose the
theme for us boot Swatch comes with
another terrific function called BS
themer and you can put it inside your
server function then when you run your
app your app will have a widget up here
in the
corner that allows you to try out
different themes to see how it looks in
your app so for example
we could try out the superhero
theme kind of nice
darker we could we could try out any of
these themes these are all boot Swatch
themes that come with our app this one
might be good if we're wireframing
something to have discussions about it
uh I like the Darkly theme and that's
where I'm going to take this app I'm
going to start here but I don't like it
out of the box I do want to change
things in the theme and I could do some
of that right here here with BS themer
for example I could change the
foreground color to a color of my
choosing uh so let's keep this so I
paste it back in here in a second but I
know that this light blue from demo Co
is a color that I believe is
um
oh here let me look it up in my notes so
I don't get the wrong yes it's
86c 7e
D so I could take the Darkly theme and
change the foreground color to be this
color I like how these letters are this
color it really pulls The Branding
through but I really hate how these
fields in the sidebar are that color I
really expect those to stay white so
maybe I'm not going to do this instead
I'll return this to what it used to be
but I have other ways to put the color
in here there's several accent colors
used by every app and I could change
those although the way I've in this app
it's not really taking advantage of
those accent colors but I could change
them I could change the fonts of the app
as we go that's uh not something I'll do
here but is an option I could change
other options for example I could turn
box
shadows and maybe mess with the spacing
and let's let's change one accent color
I wonder what happens if I change that
to
G well I crash the app uh but every time
I made a change in the app in the
console back here we weren't looking at
it but the themer was printing the code
we would need to apply that custom
scheme we came up with to our app we
could take these arguments that happen
after theme and we could put them right
into BS theme up here and then we'd have
the theme that we were looking at now I
didn't really like anything I was doing
there but I did like that there's a
Darkly theme and my app looked good with
it so I'll start there and instead of
using the themer to change the
components of my
app I think I'll manually change the
components so let's stop whatever
happened
there here's my app with the Darkly
theme here's what I want to do to it I
want to make all this text blue we'll
keep in this white I want to make some
of these backgrounds a different color I
want to change the fonts to reflect the
fonts in the logo essentially I want to
touch everything in this app to make it
a little different and by doing that
we'll be able to survey together all our
options for changing styling piece by
piece inside our shiny app sounds like a
lot but it's not let's get started so
the first thing we can do the easiest
thing might be to change the background
of the value
boxes I each value box takes a theme
argument and I could set that that to a
hardcoded color or even one of those
colors that we were looking at before
like primary secondary success these are
all colors defined with each theme and
if I reload this app I'll see that this
value box has the success color so now
it's showing up in our
app the other value boxes I'm going to
make the secondary
color it's a shade of gray it doesn't
look very different from before but to
my eyes it looks a little more inviting
a little
warmer there we go we have the secondary
color there now I don't like this green
color has nothing to do with my brand
but it does give me a method for
changing this color
here I could change the color value of
the secondary color the primary color
any of the colors in the theme in the
boot Swatch theme in the BS theme
function so if I want the success color
to
be my
86 C7 color I could set it here now
everywhere that success color appears in
the app it'll be that blue which means
I've now made that value box my company
color which is
great next I'll use that success color
to make the other parts of this app the
company color as well
so going
back
here we have the card headers that's
where our text appears the method I'm
going to use to change the color of the
card headers will be to assign them a
CSS Class A CSS class is just a set of
styling rules like color font family
size whatever that gets a appli to the
objects that share that class the
bootstrap framework is just a collection
of many many CSS classes that all do
different things but all look good
together if I can find a bootstrap class
that changes the text to the success
color then I could use that class here
because card header has a class
argument now where would I find the name
of the CSS class that does what I want
to do I'm not even someone who uses CSS
on a regular basis well there's a page
that has all of the bootstrap CSS
classes and we could search through it
if I'm looking for a class
that affects
text I could start to look through
classes that use text and I might notice
that there's these are the colors that
come with the theme a primary color
secondary color success
color I could do some experimentation
and I have and I discovered that text-
success makes the text of any object you
give this class the color that is the
success color if I want to use it I
don't need to pay attention to that dot
I could just take the name of the class
and pass it to that class argument so
this would be
text-
success and I could reuse that in any
object whose text I want to be the color
of success I'll be all my card headers
let's reload the app and see the effect
so now nothing's changed except the
color of the text and it's the success
color that's very good the next piece of
text that I want
to
well eventually I'll color this text too
but I'll use a different method to do
that I will use this class method to
change the background of the sidebar I
would like the background to be like
these backgrounds and there's a
bootstrap class for doing
that and like everything else the the
sidebar function takes a class
argument through experimentation and
induction I figured out that the
bootstrap class CSS class that would
make the
background success would be that but I
don't want it to be blue I want it to be
the secondary color so BG secondary will
change that background color so the
class of this object comes with a
styling rule that says his background is
this color the secondary color it's
looking pretty good
all right now I have this text down here
let's make that blue as well I looked
and I looked and I could not find a csss
class that would change this text but
the latest editions of bootstrap have
something Beyond CSS
classes that I could rely on and those
are
variables see what I mean about
variables let's come over here to the BS
lib page under the theming section
there's an article arcle that lists all
the theming
variables all right here's some
variables for each of these there is a
CSS class or multiple CSS classes that
use these values so there's some class
that says um make the text this gray
value but it doesn't say #f F9 fa it
says make it gray 100 and then gray 100
is a variable that contains the value to
use if I change the value contained in
grade 100 then every class that uses
grade 100 will be updated and so my
change will propagate or there we say
Cascade through my app using this
variable
system I think you could kind of imagine
how it works if you realize that success
the success color is a variable as is
primary secondary and so on so when I
change success I changed all the places
that use success to use that blue color
now the question is are there any
variables that affect
tables well we could search for
variables that affect tables and one
thing I noticed is there's a variable
called table color I wondered what color
gets changed it's probably not the
background because there's a variable
called table BG and just by trying it
out I saw that it is the color of the
text in the table so if I want the color
of the text and table to be a different
value I'll just set this to a different
value and where do I set that I set that
in the BS steam function just like when
I changed the success variable to be a
different value so this variable be
table-
color I'm going to say equal to that
same
blue reload the
app and voila we're starting to get
where we want to go now there's one big
hole in the color theming of this app so
far and that's the plots now each of
those plots are made with ggplot 2 and
with ggplot 2 you can control everything
and I mean everything about the visual
appearance of a plot but it does take a
lot of typing to fix all that to make it
look like something custom and I'd
rather skip over that luckily I can
there is an amazingly magical way to
make your plots match the rest of the
app and that is with a package called
thematic so I'll load the package of my
app with Library
thematic and then thematic comes with a
function called thematic
shiny when you add that to your app
every base R plot every lattice plot and
every ggplot 2 plot will automatically
inherit the styling of the app that
surrounds it so let's give that a try
I'll reload the
app and you see right away with that one
line of code my plots now look like they
belong here in this Darkly themed app
and it looks like they're using a set of
colors I didn't really mess with but
they look good in the app because that's
how Darkly themed works it's a set of
things that look good together all right
now this is a really nicely colored app
I want to change the fonts
though there's several ways to change
the fonts in an app but they all rely on
variables
so there are three variables that's what
I way that change fonts one of them is
called base
font one of them is called heading
font and one of them is called code
font I don't have any code appearing in
my app so I won't be working with code
font and just for a discussion right now
let's stick to just one of these let's
try to change the base
font to change one of these font
variables we could pass it the name of
any web safe font to the font that every
browsers go know and have access to we
could pass a single value here or it
could be a vector of several fonts so
you have backup fonts if for some reason
one font doesn't work I'll reload that
app we should be able to see that some
text has become Times New Roman it has I
definitely don't want to keep that but I
wanted to see that this
works but it's not going to work for me
because I want to change the font to
something that's not universally
known for example I might want to change
it to Pacifico which is a Google font
made available by Google not too hard to
get but it's not a web sa font so if I
just ran this the browser probably
wouldn't know what Pacifico is to pass
that information to the browser I could
use the helper font Google for any
Google based font use Font Google if
your users browser does not have that
font font Google will download it and
cach it for the user so they could use
it to see your
app so here's specific
makes a big difference it's also not the
font we want to use at the end of the
day but the font we do want to use it's
called lad it is essentially the default
font why are we going to use
it because it's the font that appears in
my logo so this is L it's the same font
from the subtitle highly flexible
Solutions doesn't make a good example
today because it is the the default font
but this is how we'd swap that out next
let's swap the headings to use the demoo
font that is a different font yet that
font is called op sauce Sands it's not a
Google font at all it's just a font that
I actually have the style F the font
file for and if I want to use it I could
give that file to my users's browser and
then tell them to use that font this is
a foolproof way for getting any font
into your shiny app so to give the font
a users browser I put it in this www
folder
and then next I tell the app to use it
for the
headings the way I do that is I set
heading font to a different helper
function this time is
fontface the way font face works first I
give the font a
name Open sauce Sands in case I want to
refer to anywhere and then I have to
tell it um where where that font lives
and this is a little tricky it's
something you might want to look up
because you have to use CSS syntax here
and the way the syntax works out is you
pass a URL which is a file
path to your font file assuming the font
files at the top level directory of the
web
page which is where it will be since I
put in WW folder hopefully I spelled
that correctly but it doesn't in there
you have to tell the CSS what the format
to that file is in our case the format
is true type that's what the ttf means
true type
font and now if I've have done this
right and have the right
number
parentheses could reload the
app and I don't see that working so I
either missed something or need to
restart
are open sauce Sands regular Open sauce
Sands regular
DTF format true type ah yeah I didn't
close
this so I had open a quotation mark
around this file path I didn't close
this time I closed it and now we see
that there's a legitimate change here in
the header it looks like the demo Cod
logo but oddly these card headers don't
don't follow that new font you might not
notice it but I notice it it's weird to
me but the card headers aren't
considered header
classes I can make them header classes
and then they would use the header font
and I will do that using
the a little bigger using the class
arguments I already put in here I can
give each of these multiple classes with
the same class argument for example if I
gave it the H1 class as well as Tech
success it'd be a H1 head that's a first
level header that's actually really big
I I don't want to do that I want it to
be maybe a six level header H6 that make
it the same size it is but it'
technically be a header so it would
inherit the header font as well as
inheriting the success text color let's
give that a
try all right there we go we have the
the fonts here and in all these places
so this is how the finished app looks
minus a couple things a git link some
other things but it is ready to publish
now if you want to publish a styled app
there's a couple things I can I suggest
you consider doing and I'm going to do
them right now the first is we should
hardcode into here the version of
bootstrap that we're using bootstrap
gets updated from time to time this is
always going use the latest version of
bootstrap but we wouldn't want to update
to change the way our app looks we might
not like the change so what we could do
is we could find out what version of
bootstrap we're using today with the
function version
default version five and then we could
add that as an
argument to BS theme now this will
always use version five of bootstrap to
recreate the theme that we see here
today with our eyes the second thing I'm
going to do is just something I do when
I'm when I want to share the code for a
shiny app that's definitely not always
the case but I'm going to add a GitHub
Banner that will refer back to my repo I
can could do that really easily with the
git link package all I have to do is use
the function ribbon CSS which comes in
in the git link package this call it
inside my page and it takes the URL that
that I want to link back to that's going
to be the URL of my GitHub repo I'll put
it there and I'll run the
app now that I have the app looking the
way I want publishing the app for me is
really easy because I'm inside posit
workbench and I have a posit connect
account posit connect can host shiny
apps and they're linked so I just click
publish it ask me if I want to publish
this
app and I want to publish it under the
name finished
app click publish says there's already
one there there is it's the one I showed
you at the start of the webinar I'm
going to replace it with this one and
now it's deploying the finished
app if I close the preview window we
could
see things happening down
here and it's uploading everything that
pait connect is going to need to serve
and run this app tries to open up a
pop-up window so here we go we can see
the
app while it loads the app I'll point
out I have controls over here that as
the app owner I could use to decide who
can see the app I could limit it to
specific users I don't I'd add them here
they'd be people who have accounts on my
posit connect I don't really want to
limit it anyone on my internet with
posit connect can look at this one I
could also choose what URL I want the
app to be at finished app works just
fine for me so I'll leave that the way
it is and then I could even choose what
sort of resources compute resources I
think this app needs to support it as
multiple users visit it when it's it's
all done I when I'm all done making my
selections I could share this URL with
anyone I want to see the app and it will
appear full page like this so there we
go there's our publish styled finish
shiny app thank you so much for sticking
through this with me and learning so
much about how to style your shiny apps
the take-home messages are use the BS
lib package use its excellent website
which you could find through Google to
learn all about the package you could
lay out your apps create cards create
value cards you could use classes CSS
classes to change the appearance of your
app you use CSS variables from the
bootstrap package and you could also use
themes from the boot Swatch
package um if you have any questions
drop it in the comments and we'll try
your best to answer them thank
you thank you so much Garrett for the
awesome demo and and for sharing the
code with all of us YouTube should
automatically push you over into the
live Q&A room right now but if for any
reason it doesn't it will be in the
YouTube description below as well and
I'll put it in the chat we'd love to
have you join us for the Q&A and as a
reminder you can use the YouTube chat or
the slido link on the screen right now
for anonymous questions also if you're
curious to try posit workbench or posit
connect which you you saw today
I've also included a link on the screen
to let us know and chat with our team
too with that let's go jump over to the
Q&A see you in a
second